for the fourth time in his first term
President Trump has a new White House
chief of staff late last night mr. Trump
tweeted his decision to move acting
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney out in
favor of North Carolina congressman mark
Meadows the president is spending the
weekend at his Florida resorts CBS News
White House correspondent Weezer Jang is
traveling with the president we show
what can you tell us about the timing of
this Dana CBS News has learned that this
has been in the works for weeks and for
several months Mulvaney has had a
diminishing role in the White House
especially after he received sharp
criticism for a briefing he held during
the impeachment proceedings a president
Trump wanted to wait - all of that
wrapped up before shaking things up the
timing also has to do with the 20/20
race heating up the president announced
that Mulvaney would be the special envoy
to Northern Ireland but he will also
play a big role in mr. Trump's
reelection campaign it is notable that
Mulvaney was always working under the
acting title but Meadows will be the
permanent chief of staff he has been one
of the president's fiercest defenders on
Capitol Hill and we don't have many
details yet about his transition but we
expect it will be a smooth one because
he is so close to president Trump
already familiar with his cabinet and
key staff members in fact CBS News has
learned that when senior adviser Stephen
Miller recently got married Meadows was
sitting at the same table as mr. Trump
Mulvaney was not Jeff we just thank you
very much